[Music]
we are just 16 days away from the
release of Baywatch everybody's talking
about those iconic red bathing suits the
new gang of lifeguards is about to
slow-mo run into your life and hopefully
nobody gets hurt doing we're on a set of
Baywatch here we go the spirit of the TV
show is that you have these characters
today we look great running in slow-mo
The Hoff and his gang had it down the
rock and his gang just want to do them
justice everything is better in slow I
mean I've been practicing for months
did you everybody had it down except for
Zack that good fault it was my idea with
the director at least that's what he's
trying to make people believe in the
movie Zack is the new kid with a
troubled past he's there actually
because he's technically on parole it
was basically either this or working on
the side of the road or jail so he
picked
hey watch good move Zack got in
incredible shape for the role thank as
did the ladies of Baywatch I play CJ
Parker and she is the happy-go-lucky
light-hearted lifeguard Alexandra and
Zack look up in the movie while Kelly's
love interest is John bass everyone else
has he's like insane bodies how are you
all doing this I think the number one
thing people are really gonna enjoy when
they see Baywatch is is me yep
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Music]